Glen Greenwald has been following all of
this he's host of system update on
Rumble and he joins us tonight Glenn
thank you so much for coming on
um never thought that we would be in
this position we've criticized Tick Tock
pretty consistently for a number of
years now and certainly the government
of China but this does seem like an
effort to make us more like China not an
effort to push back against China
there's so many ironies here first of
all it's kind of astonishing I've
watched the Republican party over the
last two or three years with my support
be very concerned increasingly so about
the ability of the US government to
control what it is that we hear and see
and can do on the internet that's what
the Twitter files were about that's what
all kinds of controversies were about
concerning the 2016 and 2020 election
and now the Republican Party along with
the Democratic party wants to give to
the Biden administration of an
extraordinary power which is to ban
social media platforms that Americans
are choosing to use 150 million
Americans choose to use tick tock maybe
we should educate them not to no one's
forcing them to some are children many
are adults you showed some of those that
is an extraordinary power and what is
really ironic about it as well is that
for years China and Iran and Russia were
accused of being despotic because they
wanted to ban Google and Facebook and
other U.S companies and did So based on
many of these same claims those
companies are really just propagating
propagandizing our citizenry they're
corrupting our country and destabilizing
us they're spying on us and so as you
say in the name of warding off China and
fighting China the government is now
about to embrace powers that the Chinese
government itself has long wielded to
control the flow of information in their
countries and at the very least I think
we ought to think about why this is
happening
yeah I think you may be one of the only
people saying this who's not taking
money from China in order to say it and
one of the reasons we're so grateful
that you came on is because I we know
that you are speaking in good faith and
it's and it's worth considering and
thank you for raising these questions uh
for us tonight Glenn Greenwald
a great man appreciate it thanks tiger
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight